you
hello and welcome the royal swedish
academy of sciences which discovered who
has received the 2008 swedish riksbank
prize in economic sciences in memory of
Alfred Nobel with me to discuss this
year's prize is Peter Englund secretary
for economics prize committee first
anklam thanks very much for agreeing to
talk so soon not in altus be made can we
begin by you telling us who has received
this year's prize in economic sciences
request received by Paul Krugman who is
professor at Princeton University in the
United States and he received a first
contribution to trade theory and
economic geography and so there's two
subjects there we shall involved with
globe global trade could you could you
go into a little bit more detail please
sir could you go into both the the trade
theory and the jury sits at all starting
with contributions to take trade theory
in the late 1970s and traditional trade
theory which goes back to the world by
this week's video extra and Betty Lee
explains why countries trade with each
other because they are different they
have different factor proportions as
theory says so different endowments of
capital and labor and that theory is
well equipped to explain why all
country's export agricultural products
to rich countries who in turn we would
sell industrial products cars and cars
and so on but if you look closely at
rain patters it turns out that most a
World Trade is between between the
industrial countries countries that
similarly with similar levels of
Technology with similar access to
capital and labor and they exchanged
more or less similar groups with each
other and the contribution of
provement was to help understand why
that is sir and his in short is answer
is the combination of increasing returns
to scale so it becomes cheaper to
produce goods in large series and the
fact that consumers value variety so you
want levi's jeans and I prefer Calvin
Klein as for instance and based on that
he managed to produce a theory that
explains trade much better and so this
with you that was explaining the
evolving trade between countries but
what was it was causing a shift in in
trade all the factors involved when
members of clarity well one important
factor was was the reduction of
transport costs which also something
that krugman brought into trade theory
that that wasn't wasn't present it
wasn't at center stage before transport
cost the home market matters so if you
have a large home market you can produce
larger serious and that makes you more
competitive on on the world market and
so then the part of this theory was that
the disco be called the new economic
geography which which partially explains
why that mean this migration into cities
could you explain more about answers
right so if you think the think of it if
you haven't have a large home market
that allows you to produce large
assyrian series and to to sell the goods
at lower prices but that makes that
makes a market with a large population
more attractive because because living
standards are higher so that that in
short explains why there that tends to
be migration towards the large cities
and based on that krugman developed a
theory of the interplay between between
the agricultural sector and the gospel
singers what he calls the periphery and
the core of the world Akkad so the call
being the the cities where people are
flocking to the periphery being so the
agricultural areas outside of that
precisely and so would have been the
impacts of phasic ruins theories well
largely I think but what Krugman does is
is what we call positive theory the
outsides to understand how the world
works so it's not directly policy
oriented but with the better
understanding of the world we can we we
can also make better calculations of the
effects of the various policies so one
area would be trade negotiations where
for instance World Trade Organization
now routinely use models based on prove
my theories in evaluating the effect of
different trade liberalisation measures
and so this is the diese theories that
had a big impact on economic sciences
exactly so there's a huge amount of work
that builds on Krugman's theory and in
Trey personally in the eighties and
nineties whereas now perhaps geographies
the hotter area so dudu professor
krugman's theories totally explain what
we're seeing now in terms of trade or is
it is it is there is there a balance
between what we call traditional trade
theory and new trade theory that's very
definitely definitely a balance so so
the old picture alene theory explains
part of trade patterns the new theory
based on increasing returns to scale
explains another part and then perhaps
that's a remnant that we still don't
does that right and this is this of this
surprise that's definitely sort of fits
into the pattern or for understanding
globalization which of course has a
positive and negative implications
depending on what and how you believe in
this and of course we're in this period
of economic crisis so more people never
can be interested in this prize mean is
this surprise that's been selected to
reflect that the environment were in
well I mean it's certainly not selected
with with the current crisis in mind I
mean that's not not the way the prize
committee
and can work I mean we have a sort of
longer longer time horizon so we started
thinking of this price long before we
saw the Christ is coming it is it is a
price that helps us understand
globalization I perhaps more
globalization on the real side goodson
sir goods and service flows where as the
crisis has more to do with financial
flows and although Krugman has done
research on in these areas as well
that's not what he was awarded the prize
for and did she talk to Professor
Krugman yourself did we talk to him on
the phone when we when we woke him up
this man and had to react oh he was he
was really stunned I mean he was I think
more people was more surprised than I
had expected what for thank you very
much miss franklinton for more about
this prize please visit Nobel Prize org
that's about all for this live webcast
and indeed our webcast of all the 2008
Nobel Prize announcements we hope you
enjoyed these these live webcasts and
please join us again in December will be
recovering Nobel week but from now
goodbye